bonjour à tous bienvenue sur la chaîne
de libération des instances politiques
la chaîne qui vous explique en 5 10
minutes de détail des organismes
politiques en france
aujourd'hui on va parler des députés
donc un député c'est quoi c'est qui est
bien un député est un citoyen français
d'au moins 18 ans élu au suffrage
universel direct qui a pour but de
participer au travail législatif et au
travail de contrôle du gouvernement
c'est un membre de la chambre basse du
parlement français qu'on appelle
l'assemblée nationale la chambre route
étant le sénat en tout il y à 577
députés élus pour cinq ans ils sont élus
lors des élections législatives au
suffrage universel direct donc par
l'ensemble des citoyens français
le nombre de députés dépend du nombre
d'habitants par département le loir et
cher qui n'a que trois cent trente deux
mille habitants n'a que trois députés
tous des hommes
le pas de calais qui a un million quatre
cent soixante cinq mille habitants en a
12 deux femmes et 10 hommes les députés
sont élus dans une circonscription
particulière mais représentent la nation
tout entière et doivent agir au nom de
l'intérêt général
le mode de scrutin des élections
législatives est un scrutin uninominal
majoritaire à deux tours
un seul député et son suppléant sont
élus dans l'une des 577 circonscriptions
législatives au premier tour un candidat
sera élu s'il arrive à recueillir la
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
représentant au moins 25 % des électeurs
inscrits ça veut dire que s'il ya 100
électeurs inscrits et que 50 personnes
votent réellement il sera élu au premier
tour s'il a la majorité de ces cinquante
suffrages donc 26 votes
par contre si seulement 30 personnes
votent et qu'il obtient 20 voix il ne
sera pas élu au premier tour
car bien que ce soit la majorité des
votes ça ne couvre pas le minimum des 25
% d'électeurs inscrits si personne
n'était lui dès le premier tour
d'exister alors deux possibilités pour
second tour dans un premier cas au moins
deux candidats ont obtenu un minimum de
12 5% des suffrages des électeurs
inscrits et donc tous les candidats
peuvent se présenter au second tour
dans un deuxième cas un seul où aucun
des candidats n'a obtenu 12 5% des
suffrages des électeurs inscrits et donc
seuls les deux candidats avec le plus de
suffrages peuvent se présenter au second
tour
au second tour le candidat qui obtient
le plus de suffrages est élu
peu importe si cela représente la
majorité des inscrits ou non sur ses 577
députés 556 sont élus dans les
circonscriptions des départements de
métropole et d'outre-mer comme la
guadeloupe la guyane la martinique et la
rn10 représente les collectivités
d'outre-mer 1 à saint pierre et miquelon
2 à mayotte 1 à saint barthélemy et
saint martin 1 à wallis et futuna 3 en
polynésie française et deux en nouvelle
calédonie et enfin 11 députés
représentant les français établis hors
de france
les députés sont à 26% des femmes et 74
% des hommes
ils sont 24 à avoir moins de 40 ans 94 à
avoir des 40 à 50 ans 180 à avoir de 50
à 60 ans 197 à avoir de 60 à 70 ans 80 à
avoir de 70 à 80 ans et un seul à avoir
plus de 90 il exerçait avons comme
enseigne aux salariés fonctionnaires non
enseignant professions judiciaires et
libérale commerce et industrie
professions médicales sans profession
déclaré professions agricoles ou autres
professions enfin ils font partie des
groupes socialistes écologistes et
républicains du groupe des républicains
de l'union des démocrates indépendants
du groupe gauche démocrate et
républicaine du groupe radical
républicains démocrates et progressistes
et certains ne sont pas inscrits la
place des députés dans l'hémicycle est
définie par leur groupe politique les
partis dits de droite sont à droite et
les partis dits de gauche sont à gauche
bon alors les députés comme on l'a dit
participe au travail législatif
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire eh bien
ça veut simplement dire que c'est eux
qui sont en charge avec le sénat et le
gouvernement de légiférer donc de
s'occuper des lois en effet un député
peut créer une loi présenté une loi
devant l'assemblée
ce qu'on appelle déposé une proposition
de loi examinée une loi
modifier une loi à travers des
amendements voter une loi et la revois
tes parfois en effet le président la
république qui promulguent les lois donc
qui les publient de manière à ce qu'elle
soit applicable peut demander une
nouvelle délibération de la loi ou de
certains de ses articles
et cette nouvelle délibération ne peut
pas être refusé la création ou la
modification d'une loi se fait en
commission
les commissions parlementaires sont des
groupes de travail spécialisés dans
l'étude de problèmes principalement d'un
préservatif avant leur examen en séance
publique
en gros il vérifie que la future loi est
valide par rapport à la loi actuelle il
existe huit groupes différents ou
commission parlementaire qui sont
chacune experte sur un domaine
particulier en ce qui concerne la longue
il ya la commission des affaires
économiques des affaires étrangères de
la défense et les forces armées des
affaires sociales de la culture de
l'éducation et de la communication du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire des finances
c'est elle qui vérifie aussi budget de
l'état et son emploi à l'aide de la cour
des comptes
c'est aussi elle qui contrôle
l'utilisation des fonds publics et
l'application des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale à travers des
missions d'évaluation et enfin la
commission des lois il existe aussi
d'autres commissions appelées commission
spéciale qui ont pour but d'examiner des
points très précis comme la commission
spéciale chargée d'examiner la
proposition de loi sur l'enfance des
lycées et l'adoption
un parlementaire ne peut appartenir qu'à
une seule commission il existe aussi des
commissions parlementaires au sénat mais
sont au nombre de sept
en plus du travail législatif convient
de voir des députés participent aussi au
contrôle du gouvernement et pour
contrôler le gouvernement
ils peuvent utiliser le vote de
confiance c'est une façon pour le
parlement de valider la nomination d'un
premier ministre et de son gouvernement
le premier ministre a aussi demandé le
vote une question de confiance afin de
renforcer sa légitimité s'il sent une
crise de confiance ces votes seront
demandés par le premier ministre et le
résultat est souvent positifs si le
résultat négatif de gouvernement doit
démissionner
voter une motion de censure avec 58
députés soit en 10e de l'assemblée
nationale il est possible de déposer une
motion de censure condamnée elle doit
être votée à la majorité absolue de
l'ensemble de débuter pouvoir au moins
289 x afin de faire chuter le
gouvernement
il est cependant possible pour le
président la république de refuser la
démission du gouvernement
en cas d'utilisation du 49 3 on dit que
le gouvernement engage sa responsabilité
et les députés peuvent sous 24 heures
déposé une motion de censure afin de le
faire je vais poser des questions au
gouvernement les députés peuvent
interroger le gouvernement de façon
orale ou écrite les questions orales
seront retransmises à la télévision
et peuvent être vues sur le site de
l'assemblée nationale les questions
écrites sont publiés dans le journal
officiel juger les membres du
gouvernement les députés forme avec les
sénateurs la haute cour chargée de se
prononcer sur une éventuelle destitution
du président de la république
un député s'il devient membre de la cour
de justice de la république composée de
six députés et six sénateurs et trois
magistrats peut juger les membres des
anciens membres du gouvernement
par exemple christine lagarde a été mis
en examen par cette cour pour la faire
de tapis et du crédit du havre vérifier
les nominations du président la
république comme les nominations des
membres du conseil constitutionnel
saisir le conseil constitutionnel après
le vote d'une loi 60 députés peuvent se
réunir pour saisir le conseil
constitutionnel afin qu'ils vérifient
que le texte est valide à la
constitution parmi les autres pouvoirs
du parlement français on peut noter
l'autorisation de déclaration de guerre
et d'intervention de l'armée et la
prologation de l'état de siège c'est
comme l'état d'urgence mais avec l'armée
sur toutes les questions d'intérêt
public
l'assemblée nationale peut décidé de
constituer une commission denquête vous
une mission d'information
cela peut concerner la politique du
gouvernement mais aussi tous les
organismes publics ou privés comptable
des droits des libertés ou de la santé
des citoyens
par exemple sur les essais nucléaires
français sur l'utilisation de farines
animales sur l'immigration clandestine
le président de la république peut
dissoudre l'assemblée nationale
une fois par an dès lors de nouvelles
élections législatives sont mises en
place avec le sénat l'assemblée
nationale pop est défini chaque année le
budget de l'état donc voilà c'est fini
pour cette vidéo j'espère que vous en
aurez appris un peu plus sur la députée
si vous voulez en savoir encore plus
n'hésitez pas à aller voir directement à
la source sur les sites officiels du
gouvernement
le site de l'assemblée nationale et le
site vie publique sont très bien faits
et apporte énormément d'infos n'hésitez
pas à laisser un commentaire
et à très bientôt